[Music]
okay let's clear something up the anime
ghost in the shell' from 1995 and the
live-action ghost in the shell' from
earlier this year are not the same movie
they're both adapted from the same
universe originally created in the manga
by Masamune Shirow
but they pull from different parts of
that universe unfortunately the
popularity of the 1995 anime feature
seems to have convinced someone that it
was a good idea to graft images and
sequences from that movie onto a
completely different story don't get me
wrong I like homages as much as the next
guy but the ones in ghost in the shell'
2017 don't really do it in favors the
evocative colors and sharp contrast of
the anime are replaced by drab dark
palettes that are often hard to make out
sure animation is more likely to have
crisper lines of contrast but the
live-action movie not only fails to
recreate the beauty of its predecessor
it fails to understand the purpose of
that beauty take a look at these two
shots how does each make you feel okay
for me the one on the Left draws my
attention to the best it's the brightest
part of an otherwise pretty uniformly
colored frame if you blur it out like
this you can see that there is virtually
no contrast between the interior walls
of the apartment and the cityscape
through the window
it makes for a bland blueish composition
that doesn't ask you for any further
consideration or what about this one
well the immediately recognizable
difference is the light source instead
of coming from the bed the light comes
from the window and it's blown out so
much that it creates this frame within a
frame effect that shrouds the apartment
and leaves the major in silhouette
there's great contrast here but the
purpose of the contrast is more
important it's almost as if the major
shape is cut out of the city itself in a
video I made a couple years ago I spoke
about how the 1995 anime explores the
relationship between city and person it
uses a futuristic pluralistic dynamic
Hong Kong to interrogate what it means
to build a personal identity in the age
of cyborgs it does this by visually
framing characters in relation to the
city around them and by giving us time
to content
the space where the story takes place
most notably in a three and a half
minute meditative sequence that allows
us to simply look at the city it's funny
that the live-action movie adds twenty
more minutes of runtime but can't find
any time for something like this in fact
for all the cool visuals it boasts there
is really no City at all in this movie
just a digital canvas to show off
cyberpunk ish effects the way goes to
Nichelle 2017 wants us to see the city
is in these elaborate soaring shots that
move and glide through the holographic
buildings but actual people don't see
the city that way one of the things that
2017 helped me to realize is that every
shot and the montage from the anime is
from the perspective of human beings the
camera is placed only where people could
actually stand or sit or gaze out of a
window that's how you build a sense of
place not like this in fact you can
learn a lot about what makes the anime
so great by watching the live-action
ghost in the shell' let's take a look at
this sequence for example one of my
favorite from the original story of the
garbage man in the anime we get to spend
three or four minutes with this guy and
his coworker as they work and chat he
explains that his estranged wife won't
let him see his daughter so he's hacking
into her mind to find out why she's
doing this
he even shows his colleague a picture of
his daughter but he doesn't really care
she's my beautiful precious angel see
get away I'm not interested in crap like
that in the 2017 version we get this you
want me to pay for violin too I'm going
to be around
I love that kid to pieces I do this is
amazing but when she practices that
thing is painful right why not piano
that was 14 seconds you don't see these
guys doing their job you don't get any
conversation in 14 seconds their minds
are hacked and they become zombies after
this they staged the iconic fight scene
from the anime and the water in front of
the city it's virtually a shot-for-shot
remake with a few differences like these
beautiful science versus these beige
buildings or this red shirt as a point
of focus versus this beige overcoat or
even this little smile a man momentarily
in awe of his city a brief moment like
that can add so much but ghost in the
shell' 2017 never has time for them
finally we get to the tragic moment when
the garbage man learns that he's been
fooled that all his memories of his
daughter are fake implanted by a hacker
the live-action version shoots this in a
weird glass box with a man we've spent
14 seconds with cutting all over the
place the anime takes this moment
largely in one shot
garbage man in the harsh overexposed
light of the truth the man doesn't
believe it but the cop brings out the
man's photographed and asks him what he
sees I had a picture of her she was
there
she was smiling like an angel I'm sorry
putting through this town come on who do
you see this is all Aloha in the anime
we get this tragic little arc one that
echoes the larger themes of the film and
it's sequenced brilliantly following
this is the scuba diving scene where
major ruminates
on her own identity and following that
is the montage I mentioned before where
we get to ruminate where the ideas from
both scenes compound and reverberate
across the city in the live-action movie
the character is a throwaway the scene
is disconnected the scuba diving scene
is isolated as well elsewhere in the
movie and any time for us to dwell on
these ideas is non-existent the worst
part about it is that the story ghost in
the shell' 2017 wants to tell is
actually really good it's from a part of
the TV series the standalone complex and
it features the revolutionary - zeg here
played by Michael Pitt whose backstory
is tragic and whose ideology is profound
but we don't get to explore any of that
because 2017 is busy trying to
accommodate two stories there are
interesting things about both but we get
nothing but the surface level of either
those who adapt works of art should be
given the creative license to make the
story work for them but you can't just
mine the source material for parts
adaptations and remakes don't require
strict adherence or obedience or even
necessarily respect just an
understanding of what made the original
so powerful in the first place
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Squarespace if you want to make a
website and you want it to be just a
really easy process Squarespace has some
beautiful award-winning designer
templates to choose from that makes the
process simple it's got 24-hour customer
service no upgrades nothing to install
no patches ever and thinking your domain
name is really easy you can start your
free trial at squarespace.com and if you
use the offer code nerdwriter you can
get 10% off your first purchase I'll see
you guys next Wednesday